[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quant à moi quand lui que ou piller tout
jeune à qui michael faisait souvent des
surprises
il avait toujours des sommes
extraordinaires dans son bec vous tous
sur tous à tambour et convoite itunes à
mon principe entendu pas vrai vous
parlez pas si tu fumes aux garçons j'ai
besoin de toujours bon cette fois mais
pas ma vie que faut-il pas les choses
c'est quoi
mais il faut faire quelque chose la
dombes au bec tour et dont je dépasse
mon âge c'est pourtant un bloc notes en
ouvrant grand s'il vous plaît mais sa
mort comme un crocodile de passage chez
moi on s'est fait un nom et alpin soirée
attention ça recommence je record
dépassement ben vrai ça le met nadal
tente ou non et à toute la famille
parent d'élève je me sens vieux sera là
là là leurs offres au mercy beau garçon
vêtu l'accompagnait je vais voir le
grand yaka à profit un rendez vous avec
délai ni alors jeunes racistes que toi
amuse toi bien
si vous avez encore des pansements
premier mémoire d' art en vrac pas
revoir tout aille au lard à wall et
coquine et ben non on a les cédantes en
étant salage allons là c'est moi aller
jouer ailleurs émis revenais pas sinon
je me met très en colère allez
disparaissez sauver voir bérénice je
n'ai pas besoin de vous allez dame est
ou au moins ne vais pas me mettre en
prison
[Musique]
et hélas bien phase va vous libérer
après mon rendez-vous avec des rennais
chez blizzard c'est insolite fait
dangereux que signifie cette
construction au beau milieu du passage
si le grand yaka viens par ici il ne
pourra pas repasser
il faut déplacer tout ça jusqu'ici et
bien mhk au travail
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
des régions on se couvre aussi que c'est
pour toi béléné anti timgad
qu'est ce que c'est au tour du groupe
profonde mais c'est moi qui les paie non
pas psy des castagnettes ans j'adore les
castagnettes tu permets que je
t'embrasse
[Musique]
aïe aïe aïe on vous balance dom alors
d'un profond merlus savons nous passer
devant nous mais nos titus je sais
comment on dresse une pince à l'aise
garde au port de busan bully
d'incroyables pas et bien pourtant pas
fait passer comme ça et après après les
plus grandes victoires
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]